el huracán a aída se degrada a medida
que continúa su impulso hacia el noreste
pero los residentes de luisiana están
haciendo un balance del daño dejado a su
paso
las cosas simplemente empezaron a
desmoronarse a volarse no tengo un lugar
seco en mi casa mi techo se cayó perdí
toda mi ropa mis muebles mis utensilios
todo ahorita mismo no tengo nada
escombros árboles caídos y líneas
eléctricas llenaron las calles de nueva
orleans pero la ciudad se ha librado de
las inundaciones generalizadas que se
vieron después del huracán katrina en
si hay luz al final del túnel hoy es
difícil verlo es nuestro sistema de
diques el que ha funcionado
extremadamente bien ha habido una
evaluación preliminar de daños de diques
no creemos que haya un solo dique en
ninguna parte ahora que realmente se
haya quebrado que haya fracasado
aunque los diques aguantaron un par se
desbordaron las marejadas ciclónicas y
las fuertes lluvias han provocado
inundaciones en varias áreas incluidas
la place los esfuerzos de rescate están
en camino vía marítima y aérea los
vientos de más de 200 kilómetros por
hora derribaron cables eléctricos en
todo el estado lo que provocó que más de
un millón de hogares y negocios estén
sin electricidad los daños han sido tan
extensos que las autoridades dicen que
podría tardar semanas en hacer las
reparaciones los hospitales de luisiana
ya estaban rebosando de pacientes de
ccoo y 19 antes de la llegada de ied a
la pérdida de electricidad solo agrega
aún más presión a un sistema de salud
bajo tensión